one of the biggest successes and of
paramount importance
for what joe biden has done in this
presidency so far is something that has
barely made headlines and it is that joe
biden has confirmed more judges
than trump
obama and george w bush at this point in
their respective presidencies it is not
the supreme court that's absolutely true
but it is of massive massive importance
business insider and others talking
about this how biden out did trump obama
and george w bush in confirming federal
judges by this point in office a feat
overshadowed by war and inflation and it
has been
joe biden has confirmed more federal
judges at this point in his tenure than
any president since jfk
biden's court picks have also been the
most racially ethnically and gender
diverse
but his judicial winds have been
overshadowed by news of inflation war
and the fbi mar-a-lago search this is a
major major deal as of august 8th which
was 566 days into biden's tenure the
senate had already confirmed a
record-setting 75 judges nominated by
biden to federal courts according to the
pew research center trump didn't do that
obama didn't do that george w bush
didn't have those numbers you have to go
back to jfk
who at this point in his presidency
we're talking about the 60s folks
had confirmed 102 judges
um as of august 26
joe biden had gone from 75 to 78 and
that includes appeals and district court
judges along with one supreme court
justice
this is interesting because i mean
listen
biden is not incorrectly seen as boring
and milk toast
it's just what it is in a sense you
could make the case that that's exactly
what the country needed to sort of
recover from donald trump a guy who
every day was ridiculing a disabled
journalist drawing with a sharpie on a
hurricane map i i'm not going to give
you the list i'd have to sit here for
five hours giving you the list
and
when you take a guy
who's
you could say his the reasons many
people didn't like biden
include
he's been in dc for a generation
and um he's not
exciting in the sense that
certain candidates are and i i want to
be careful here because
some of these aren't really criticisms
but they they were used as criticisms
what during the primary
um
relatively centrist uh uh
seeming
but actually on paper was the most
progressive democratic nominee that i
can remember i mean on paper biden was
to the left of barack obama
the things that joe biden has done and
there are many criticisms of uh there
are many criticisms of the biden
administration
without a doubt i mean every presidency
has criticisms but
quietly for giving more student loan
debt than any president in history
quietly getting more judges confirmed at
this point in his presidency than any
president dating back to john f kennedy
in a sense you could argue that this was
maybe exactly what was needed
to get out of or to recover from donald
trump someone completely predictable
right i mean this was i kept saying
during the primary
all of these people saying biden's going
to be some secret right winger
or biden's going to be some secret
communist never believable but the
people on the right were saying that no
biden was going to be a completely
predictable
center-left democrat who on paper
is the most left-leaning democratic
nominee
at least in in many many decades and
that's what it's worked out to be
and so i can give you my list of the
things i would love for joe biden to do
that he hasn't done
what happened to health care reform what
about decriminalizing cannabis what
about of course we can always come up
with lists of things we would like
presidents to do that they have not done
but it is starting to be remarkable
the amount that actually has been
accomplished and much of it with
extraordinarily little fanfare and i
have to say this this isn't like gushing
praise it's just sort of a trait of joe
biden
he does it without the self-centered
bombast
of somebody like donald trump and when
you expect because of the trump era a
president
to be
tooting his own horn or you could use
you know more graphic metaphors than
that if you want um about the things
that they have accomplished trump did it
about things he didn't even really do
right we built the wall no you didn't
what are you talking about
you didn't build the wall anyway because
joe biden doesn't do that i think that's
part of why many of these
accomplishments have been have been
quietly done and also that stories like
ukraine inflation and others have
pervaded the news to a greater degree so
i'm as curious as anybody else
where will joe biden's approval be
on midterm election day in just eight or
nine weeks and what impact will that
have on democrats ability to hold the
senate and although it's less likely
potentially hold the hold the house and
we'll update those numbers for you later
this week remember that this wednesday
august 31st 6 pm eastern we're doing a
member only david pakman show town hall
this will be limited in terms of
participation to our website members
anybody can watch it'll be streaming
live on youtube twitch and facebook at 6
pm eastern only our website members will
be invited to participate in this one
and you can add yourself to that
exclusive group of people
uh by signing up at joinpakman.com